Ronald I've done it I found your
assistant and he's dope his name is jean
Ralphy Oh jean-ralphio big t mr. Swanson
two things one it is an absolute honor
to meet you two who is that hot intern
chick out there because honestly yeah
take a seat right here we go so
jean-ralphio you got him right here
leave a message after the bit why do I
want you as my assistant starters access
to the ilis clubs and that's just for
starters I will work for you I'll be on
you 24/7 I'll be like your family I'm
here when you get here in the morning
sure enough I'll be there tucking into
bed at night don't worry it's not gay do
we have questions I think our only
question is when can you start right now
let's do it
thank you for coming in we will talk
cool I feel good about this I know you
can hit me up on Facebook anytime day or
night you know that right
take care buddy boom so what do you
think of your new assistant I want to
punch you in the face so bad right now
what okay message received I'll keep
looking
thank you bring me the opposite of him
jean-ralphio big t what it do nephew
jean-ralphio
I have a hot investment opportunity that
you were gonna want to jump all over hit
me with a daddy the snakehole lounge
order it he's looking for investors no
way yesterday if you would ask me I
would have said no but thank God my
grandfather just died so I am awesome I
have 4,000 bucks
all I need you to do is kick in six G's
and then you and I are part owners of
the hottest nightclub in Pawnee also
sorry about your grandpa no worries he
was a dick here's the thing I can kick
in five g's I should be enough right no
it's not enough I just said I need six
G's what about your trust fund my
parents had it amended I don't get
anything to them 50 which is a waste cuz
I'm gonna be a billionaire and Costa
Rica by then eating dolphins and hanging
out with lady singers it's not a huge
deal just sit tight I'll take care of it
you want to come home with me don't you
work at lady Foot
oh okay to the ends of the ope she's the
dopest little short again all Pawnee
Indiana why don't you stop a party you
two remind me of me and my husband
George I got a nil speech so I brought
it an expert jean-ralphio got throw
something on you see if it feels good
sure okay this is what I would do I
would start with a joke joke Vince
Vaughn quote obviously swingers or
Crashers Fred Claus talk about Andy's
ex-girlfriends quote from Love Actually
hold back your tears pause drop the
microphone get out of that [ __ ] yo
Robbie Oh take me there for you Ben you
care to help us with the paperwork man
is that your real name
yes oh you could do better than that I'm
gonna help you out right now your name
is Angelo Angelo thank you so much for
coming out get a thicker tie it looks
weird on you makes your head look like a
fish secondly I don't know where the
paperwork is but when you find it can
you take care of it for us we don't have
any pens cuz we're afraid it's gonna
leak in our shirts lastly I hate the
name Angelo I'm gonna switch it up for
you right now your new nickname is jello
shots
everything about that Jay shut down
Ralphie Oh looking hot big t Oh what
damn girl were you trying to impress
just kidding I know walk away
yeah you gotta try snakejuice if you
like it you got to talk it up all night
if you don't I'll shave John Ralphy O's
head yeah I'd like to see that hit me a
lot riding on this
[Music]
damn if that isn't delicious are to the
ultimate and then desist once got
swagging the size of Big Ben clock you
gotta end it on the ride know what I
have had it I got it now we have a
special presentation courtesy of the
folks at entertainment720 hope you
brought a change of clothes cuz your
eyes are about to piss tears you nasty
alcohol that you invented government
employees can't use their power to
enhance their personal wealth I totally
get your point Chris it won't happen
again I just don't see any way around it
you're gonna have to sell your shares in
the snake no deep pain this guy
bothering you this is my boss okay yeah
you want me to write a rap about your
name yes go B to the O to the SS
do what he say and you'll be successful
what up big t stop this must be the
lovely Donna I Shantae listen beautiful
let's cut the bull right you want this I
definitely want this th wants this well
let's seal this devil's three-way right
here right now step one we buy into this
club step two we roll over to the club
either new Mercedes Benz or my pre-owned
Acura Legend step 3 I'd a ger you on the
dance floor just bounce bounce bounce
bouncing now all the ladies say it
bounce bounce bounce bounce bounce you
say sexy I'm out why I hate that guy mmm
sorry to hear the news tone we're gonna
miss you around the club hey you own
shares to wedding Kris make you so
because Kris doesn't know you know what
snitches get stitches Donna come on
don't I'm a natural mind maker
I got any government for the connections
this was supposed to be the thing that
led to the other thing it's like when
VIN did boiler room that's what led to
him being xxx doing furious yeah no
listen I don't like all this negativity
man why don't you turn that frown upside
digiti huh this sucks man it's pretty so
let's go
it's my birthday produce it is looking
forward to tomorrow yes about that I was
wondering is there any chance we could
reschedule I just want to make sure
everything's up to my world-class
standees I like to keep my appointment
son and I like others to do the same of
course yes no problem
8:00 a.m. tomorrow I think you're gonna
be very impressed with our presentation
our presentation who else is joining you
Ronon Ralphy oh that's me
I didn't realize you were a part of this
of course he is he's my business partner
Shh
clean business partner now and forever
hold up forever 21 21 gun salute salute
your shorts kibosh I just reassociate it
all over the mustache
that is one of many skills he brings in
this business partnership little shrimp
ah okay rethink that move son there you
go sorry that took forever yeah maybe
you missed me oh look at this
jean-ralphio
oh hey Andy Andy that's alright name
that's not right name thank you yeah are
you guys are you guys hanging out
together
yeah maybe you know he asked me out so
many times I guess he wore me down I'm
very persistent coming here yeah I can
hear you I can come up one time I waited
outside a woman's house for five days
just to show her how serious I was about
wanting to drill her turns out it was
the wrong house she loved the story
anyway we got to third base over the
pants
so cute yeah super cute Wow right do you
want a Remy Martin probably good okay
I'll get you one there we go
are you okay some do you get any sleep
not really
I stayed up most of the night but that's
not important let me tell you about
rent-a-swag
no need Tom I'm in I like doing business
with serious people and when you removed
yourself from the company of that [ __ ]
you showed me you're a serious person
you have your startup money Wow
I appreciate it Tom et you just missed
the craziest of crazies clubs girls
dancing naked mom argument police
fleeing the scene hiding in a dumpster
coming here crashing on your couch for a
week cause technically I'm homeless
hey mustache I'm gonna hit the couch you
know Abby this is Monalisa Saperstein my
new sales associate one ELISA Saperstein
does that mean oh yeah she's my sister
my twin sister from the same mister
thank you so much for hiring Monalisa it
means so much to me even though honestly
she's the worse she's the worst person
in the world huge skank terrible but
thank you means a lot of course gotta
keep it in the family
yeah but does it have to be this family
actually that reminds me the boss man I
need to leave early today because my
shrink got me and him tickets to a
pitbull concert and I already committed
to that and so if you say that I can't
go it's like you're taking something
away from me
stories really busy I can I need you
just stay I totally hear you
um I also don't like what you're saying
so if you say no I will start a fire in
the bathroom okay I guess you can go
yeah I know again what'd I tell you huh
she's the worst in the world
John Ralphie
you